the new year will likely bring crucial
developments in the fight to improve our
health in 2017 we've seen headlines
about new guidelines for blood pressure
and the Oakley at crisis being declared
a public health emergency plus the fda
approving gene therapy for childhood
leukemia and how gene editing is
spurring hopes that pigs could become
organ donors next year we could see new
advances in gene editing to cure prevent
diseases that's good and better vaccines
to fight the flu our doctor David Eggers
joins us at the table to bring us
up-to-date you know all the season we
kept hearing that flu vaccine is not as
great as it normally is but you're
saying what to that well the flu vaccine
wasn't as good in Australia but here
certainly the numbers looks like it's
reasonable but even if it doesn't
prevent the flu it's going to temper it
down so get that flu vaccine it's
critical that we have mass immunity in
this country to things like the flu but
you're talking about better vaccines in
2018 we always like to get a good shot
so what do you what are you bringing to
the tailor to major advances in the
vaccine the first is one that I had this
week's which is a shingles vaccine
remember a third of us are going to get
shingles so it's a reactivation of
chickenpox we all don't even know what
shingles is to be honest with you it's a
reactivation a chicken it comes on hard
it hits a third of us 200,000 cases a
year the old vaccine was okay but this
new vaccine is recommended for everybody
50 and older I got it this week it's a
pain in the arm but it's gonna prevent
me from getting a pain across my body in
the future and then it's a universal flu
vaccine this notion of once a year going
in and getting a shot for the flu
hopefully that's a thing of the old and
the new now is we can target not the
outside of the flu vaccine that changes
but the inside that's more stable and so
those are in clinical trials now and
very exciting but a universal means you
just do it once it's over or you want
you may be a booster a decade down the
road but yes it's not gonna be a yearly
shot that's the dream we've been hearing
about the promise of gene therapy for
many years now it is 2018 the year where
it's actually gonna come into fruition
it's wild and so we have this gene
CRISPR that and it's DNA and so we saw
last year they went into a fetus and
they actually change it took away a
heart disease
well now we're gonna see clinical trials
across the board and diseases with this
technology to edit DNA a spellchecker
you can imagine in the future a child
not being born again with a genetic
disease but as we know from spell
checkers sometimes autocorrect can say
something you don't mean with CRISPR is
who is monitoring how they so they don't
go too far in editing genes do you want
to tell us something about something
that happened with autocorrect in but no
you really hit an important point which
is I don't matter who regulates this and
if we regulate it here so we're just
gonna go to Canada and get it done but
yes we need real leadership here because
while we can get rid of an inborn error
of a genetic disease what if someone
wants to make their child bigger or
smarter or blonde or whatever they want
to do they conceivably can do so this is
an area like spider-man says with great
power comes great responsibility a lot
of ethical questions surely and what are
your biggest concerns about next year
well that's it I mean that's the biggest
concern is who's in charge to get
normative behavior change you need
leadership and right now in the health
space which is almost a third of our
economy we don't have real leadership
and so I you know we did Mayor Bloomberg
was a great health leader for the city
of New York we haven't had a great one
since can I just say I almost didn't
recognize you this morning because you
didn't have on your traditional black
sweater it threw me and word on the
street is last night at the Christmas
party people fell down on the dance
floor when they saw you walk in the door
not wearing black or breaking out of
your shell what four years ago and it
makes me you know a little uncomfortable
now I'm doing it yes does it really make
you uncomfortable yes David he's a new
man with that shingles vaccine Thanks